j'ai eu une année très difficile après
ma séparation et écrire cette chanson
était très important pour moi
c'est un moyen simple de canaliser mes
émotions
j'ai écrit cette chanson pour moi j'ai
aussi le sentiment qu'elle était
destinée à tant de femmes qui avaient
besoin d'une tribune et d'une voix pour
les représenter
[Applaudissements]
faut qu'elle lâche l'affaire au bout
d'un moment ça fait 6 mois qu'elle fait
son business là-dessus ils ont des
enfants ensemble non les enfants
ensemble
et pardon mais c'est elle qui l'a quitté
donc si elle est temps attaché à lui
elle avait qu'à mettre son ego de côté
et rester avec lui
c'est pas parce qu'on est chez une meuf
tout nu dans un lit
contrôle mais c'est bon sa femme non
mais parfois on est obligé de chercher
ses clés et puis donc tu enlèves un
vêtement tu lui attends je sais pas si
elles sont là pendant les vacances
au milieu du village merci beaucoup
merci tu es d'accord avec moi
je vais te dire moi je je vous rappelle
un pote un jour il s'est fait choper et
par une une
autre meuf ans il avait le zizi dans le
voilà
c'est pas du tout ce que tu crois
[Applaudissements]
avec la variante je ne la connais pas
tu arrêtes avec ça non mais c'est fou
ces gens non mais je te jure oui je sais
pas du tout d'accord avec toi Shakira
tous les droits moi je suis team Shakira
et je trouve que si elle a le droit en
tant qu'artiste pardon la création c'est
un exutoire pour vendre et bah tant
mieux
et pardon mais excusez-moi
excusez-moi pardon mais
je vais vous dire la vérité si je peux
me permettre vous en foutez vous gênez
énormément Guillaume et Raymond
piqué à fond ils adorent le foot je peux
dire un truc qui n'est pas politiquement
correct mais quand tu es une extrémiste
de la fidélité pardon mais ne te mets
pas avec une star du foot
tu ne supportes pas tu ne supportes pas
l'éventualité que ton mec parle à
d'autres nana et voir ailleurs etc ne
sort pas avec une star du foot ils sont
sollicités H24 ils sont tout le temps
mais arrêtez franchement je veux dire la
vérité Shakira alors on va redescendre
sur terre mais oui elle va pécho Raymond
il va aller pisser sur les murs
il y aura pas de Waka Waka
que parce que c'est un joueur de foot
non il a tout le monde tromper c'est pas
bien j'ai juste toutes les nanas qui
sortent avec des joueurs de foot qui
sont une parmi 150000 et qui tombe de
1000 étages en disant ah il m'a trompé
mais sans blague
il va pas pour le training bien meilleur
normal alors je dis pas normal quoi
les plus belles chansons d'amour c'est
des ruptures d'accord donc c'est bien
voilà tu vois aujourd'hui voilà les plus
belles chansons d'amour c'est des
ruptures donc d'accord qu'il fasse une
chanson pour sa rupture qu'elle se
guérisse mais qu'elle ne se disent pas
je suis la porte-parole de toutes les
femmes larguées elle a rien à voir avec
les problèmes des femmes qui sont
larguées
elle est magnifique
pour moi la vie va commencer
Christophe vous intéresse j'ai la
traduction de la chanson qu'elle a
écrite
contre une twingo une Rolex contre une
Casio tu m'as laissé la belle-mère avec
la presse à la porte et des dettes mais
c'est marrant au moins se défend bien la
raison avec une chanson puisqu'il rigole
c'est bien quoi
je te déteste à mourir
[Applaudissements]
en tout cas cette montre c'est pour la
vie et il est arrivé à l'entraînement
avec une twingo il a l'humour quand même
hein c'est génial